foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the ponds
Moving and Storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we talk about
your life your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality joined by my colleague
George Campbell Ramsey personality as
well and we are here for you it's a free
phone call Triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five so
camel and Coleman on duty for you today
love alliteration and I'm here for it I
do I do but we have a k and a c there
for keeping score at home let's get
right to it Stephanie joins us the
suburbs of Atlanta Georgia Alpharetta
Georgia Stephanie how can we help
hello how are you both thank you for
taking my call
um so I've been following the principles
for the last two years we actually just
bought our home listening to the 25 of
our take-home pay 15-year fixed
um and now we're ready to go on to step
four but because I've never invested I'm
34 and I don't know much about other
than what I've heard on the call on the
show
I I hear like maxing out Roth IRAs but
with only three months left in the
academic in the in the year does that
mean like putting the 6 000 in three
months how does that work like maxing
out Roth IRAs my company does offer that
option
so your company is a Roth 401k correct
yes okay the IRA would be outside of
your employer
oh okay now first of all way to go on
doing that the housing with our
parameters that's impressive most people
say it's impossible Stephanie can you
just tell people out there that it can
be done
it can be done it took me about a year
and a half to get my husband on board
but once I had him on board we were just
gazelle intends a certain extent uh
we're looking at houses during this yes
because they're in the crazy housing
market we actually bought it as it
started to calm down a little bit right
before the interest rates went up but
best timing we love the house and now
we're just like okay let's keep the
momentum going and go right into
investing and not just get comfortable
so possible and we are very happy so
thank you guys yeah so what's your
household income
uh we're at 185 uh fantastic
and that is grossernet
no wow that's incredible okay so 15 of
your household gross income would be how
much have you done the math on that I'm
guessing you you guys are making well
over 200 at that point
well yeah well over 200
um
I can speak for myself and saying I'm
doing 15 my husband hasn't quite got on
board with that set so I just plan on
doing my portion of the income
um investing now hold on you said he's
not on board with that step
he's not it's a little weird he um is
coming from a very
um wealthy family and they've kind of
just told him that he's inheriting a
good portion so he doesn't really have
the urgency but
you know I do so okay can you do my
steps wow well I'll speak in in
generalities then since he's not totally
on board but you're you're right if you
have a Roth 401k you can do all 15 in
there what you're saying is Well I'm not
gonna be able to Max it out from October
to December now you can increase the
percentage to get you closer to 15 but
you can't do 100 of your paycheck you
guys need to put food on the table
yeah and so you could max out two Roth
IRAs which is going to be six thousand
dollars each and you can do that up
until tax time and so it doesn't have to
be by the end of the year for the IRAs
it would have to be for the 401K
got it so one the 401ks until December
31st yes and the other one's until April
exactly
and uh are you guys working with a
financial advisor or smart investor Pro
right now
that's the next step I think once the
house is very 30 days I'll leave it in
the house so that's the next step is
getting a financial advisor I'm hoping
that helps get him on board too make
sure he's there don't just go alone and
say I'm meeting with a financial advisor
and he goes okay whatever I got Mom and
Dad's inheritance so I'm not worried
about that you guys have to be doing
this I want to dig into that if I may
sure uh Stephanie how is assuming he's
going to get this inheritance upon his
parents death is that correct how old
are they
not old but uh they're in their early
60s
yeah I mean I just I would really
challenge him on that mindset what
happens if they live till 95 and now you
guys are 65 and he's broken retirement
hoping George you took the words right
out of my mouth what about Prince
Charles Prince Charles thought he was
going to be the king pretty soon his mom
lived forever the guy's in his 70s
taking the throne you know you can't
Bank on it's got analogy on him thank
you very much a little pop culture
wisdom wow a royal family trivia well
but it's true though George yeah I mean
I would really challenge your husband on
that kind of thinking that well we're
just gonna we you know our way through
life because because we got a hefty uh
settlement coming our way and here's the
other thing mom and dad could change the
will at any time I was also thinking
that too that worries me to bank on that
that's icing on the cake to me that's a
nice blessing a nice Legacy but while
we're alive we're doing everything we
can in our power to set ourselves up
yeah for financial I'm trying to affect
his safety gland a little bit he seems
like he's just running around in a
padded room you know
you know we can do whatever we want it's
gonna be okay
and I think that's dangerous and I think
that I would really challenge his Logic
on that a little bit that's just a
little extra to get him there but I
agree with George he needs to be there
and sit with the financial advisor and
get a picture do you guys have a tax Pro
as well
you don't okay I with your income levels
I would highly recommend you can jump on
Ramsay Solutions and connect with a
smartvester pro and a tax Pro who can
help walk you through this to make sure
that you're maximizing getting all the
tax advantages that you can doing things
the right way uh especially when it
comes to the the IRA piece so I'd
connect with both of those folks and get
a plan now that you guys are in this
investing mode do you have kids
we have a three-month-old oh how
exciting so on top of starting to invest
for retirement you get to invest for
that three month old and help help cover
College yeah 529 plan that's State
specific you can choose a state that's
not Georgia and again a smart investor
Pro can walk you through all the
different options for you and you might
find that the Utah 529 plan is actually
better versus an education savings
account so they can walk you through all
that but I'm just so proud of you guys
this is an exciting new phase for you
yes and I know it feels like do you feel
like you're behind because you're 34.
and you're just starting investing I
think about it yes but I didn't think
about investment
on getting the house and these PODS of
stuff for and did just a 3B option at
that route
um
I yeah I don't want to say I feel behind
but sometimes I do when I now I'm like
what do I do it's the same as like a
foreign world to me sure well I just
want to tell you it's you're not too
late and a lot of people out there
they're starting it's even when they're
28 they go I should have been investing
earlier when you're 50 I should have
been investing earlier and uh the best
time to plant a tree was 10 years ago
the next best time is today and so I
love that you guys are focused on the
future you've got a long life ahead of
you to invest to become
multi-millionaires to be outrageously
generous because that's what this plan
is all about and so keep your sights set
you can be investing you can be giving
you can enjoy your life and spend some
of it and with that income with no debt
you guys are in an amazing place so I'm
proud of you awesome way to go Stephanie
fun stuff we'd love to hear it yeah you
know it you pointed this out right out
of the gate you know it is rare that we
we run into a caller that is you know
hey we did we we did the 15 uh 15 years
yes uh uh uh mortgage and and and put it
down but it's rare we're trying to talk
people into that
oh oh I know let me tell you something
everyone goes well my City's different
Kane you don't understand my situation
yeah yeah it can be done and but yet
they got a great investment in that area
as well you want to stay off of 400.
if you don't know that area well stay
off of Highway 400 that'll change years
off of your life dangerous too much time
there uh all right so hey we're just
getting rolling we gotta uh we got some
advertisements to take care of pay the
bills but we'll be right back this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
we're thrilled you're with us this is
where we talk about your life your money
your work your relationships I'm kid
Coleman joined by George Campbell it's a
law firm of camel and Coleman we were
talking about that the other day it just
sounds like a solid Law Firm it does it
really does uh but uh rest assured if
you're brand new to the show we give no
legal advice at all no uh just uh just
bad there's a reason we're here just bad
dad humor is is what you're hearing
right now so let's get to the phones
Grand Rapids Michigan is where Julie is
Julie how can we help
hey guys
um I wanted to know if I should take the
four thousand dollars I have in savings
to pay off a leased vehicle that I have
um that we've leased tell us more it's
about twenty four thousand dollars
um well we had two lemons a couple years
ago that like were just
sinkers when it came to our our cash
flow so we ended up leasing which I know
is a very poor choice but it's worked
out better for us financially and this
vehicle that we have we could go out and
buy a newer vehicle or a different
vehicle but
um it's a twenty four thousand dollars
to just buy out this car that's the
early buyout amount
yes and we have 14 000 in savings and
then obviously our thousand dollar
emergency fund but have no debt
okay
at all except for our house
so you've got 14 in savings you have the
24 000 early buyout how is it going to
work
well should we take
and then take a loan where I'm like why
don't we just do the Fourteen thousand
dollars and just then we we don't have
to take that as significant amount of a
loan out so you're saying you would take
out a ten thousand dollar loan
yeah to cover the difference
yes yeah it beats it beats 24 000 and
then would you sell that car
well I don't think so I think we would
keep it how quickly could you pay it pay
the ten thousand dollar loan off
I think within a year what's your
household income
190 oh gross you could pay it off sooner
than that you think it would take a year
to pay off ten thousand dollars making
190. where's your money going Julie
um my three kids Catholic schools there
it is
there it is Julie I'm so sorry that
George yelled at you George there's no
need to it's always the private school
Ken you know this life it's very it's
just it's our boat in our Cottage and
everything else and the cottage no no I
just live in northern Michigan and I'm
always joking we send our kids to
Catholic school so that's that's our
extra flow right there okay yeah the car
is not too much value considering your
income the problem is kind of taking the
shortcuts that have got us to the in
this pickle here in this brined cucumber
if you will nice you like that can do I
see what you did there yeah I mean in
this case if you guys wanted to go down
to your local credit union and get a
personal loan and pay it off really
really I don't I don't want a year I'm
talking two months
okay whatever you got to do making 190.
I mean you guys are bringing 10K in
every single month yeah we are so where
is it going other than the private
school we got to make some sacrifices
and some changes at least temporarily
until we're completely out of debt
because once you do that Julie you still
don't have an emergency fund
yes and so we need to build that up
really quickly go back go back to that I
know because our goal is like 30 000 and
anyway are you guys investing right now
as well
we are okay I would recommend you pause
all investing and remember this is for a
short period of time to give you as much
margin as possible so that you're in
pain for as little time as possible
okay what are you contributing in your
investing each month do you know that
number or round number
well I mean I do my 401k
he's going to that 19 19
it's kind of a long story so my husband
we've owned businesses for like the last
10 years which didn't bode well so it
was really my income but now my husband
has a a good job and so
um anyway it's just been within the last
10 months that he's had a steady income
so we kind of are out of I mean we never
really swimming in debt but like we're
finally at a good clip if that makes
sense so I've always invested way more
in my 401k because he didn't have any
you know retirement the reason I asked
you the question is because what George
is saying that's a real number I want
you before we leave you on this call I
want you to understand why he's telling
you to pause invest in your 401k so how
much are you contributing to the 401K
each month roughly 19 equates to how
many dollars
I don't know I would have to go I think
it's like 885 okay actually see how
quickly you pay off ten thousand almost
another thousand bucks yeah you can
throw at this thing
to get rid of it ASAP
okay that makes sense yes I want you to
catch that it's great advice from George
because you can quickly with that amount
of money pay off the car
and then jump right back into investing
and it's not like you're that far behind
on investing George and so the amount of
time she's taking off to pay off it's
not like she's falling and Julie I'm
gonna challenge you guys to not take out
a personal loan but to scrape together
that ten thousand and just pay it off
with your 14. Okay add 10 in the next
two months and then just pay it off and
then we're done with this thing
I think I think that's going to go
faster than you guys taking out another
loan now we're moving the Monopoly piece
over here so uh I think you got this you
know what to do now it's convincing your
husband to do it too oh boy that's the
hard part
uh all right let's stay on theme shall
we George Leighton is joining us in
Clarksville Tennessee not too far from
Ramsey World HQ Leighton how can we help
well I've got a question
um I'm 19 years old I work for the City
of Clarksville Gas and Water Department
um I make about 40
000 a year salary
um this year I should make about 45 to
50 with overtime
um now my question is I've got a 2018
Dodge Ram
um and it's I owe about twenty four
thousand dollars on it now the problem
is I don't have a problem paying it and
you know paying the insurance and all
that it's just I have a company vehicle
I have a government vehicle that I drive
Monday through Friday so it's hard to
justify paying almost six seven hundred
dollars a month with insurance and a
Truck note you know to not drive it no
and you rarely drive it on the weekend
so you're saying you don't even need a
personal vehicle right now
at the moment no the only the only
reason I need the truck and it's it's on
the weekends like I said when I drive it
on the weekends when I pull my boat and
that's that's the only reason well we
can get a cheaper boat puller that's a
real expensive way to do that
exactly and see I got the I started at
gas and water when I was 18. um okay and
so well I got the truck when I was 18.
just what could you sell it for high
school you owe 24 what could it sell for
today private sale
well private Kelly Blue Book Market at
about 26 or 27. I love them but I had I
had it appraised and they only offered
now it was kind of like a I mean it
wasn't a well-known dealership
Layton dealerships are never going to
appraise it at the actual value you can
sell it to somebody on the market Kelly
Blue Book is where you're where you're
going
okay so sell it private seller sell it
you know Facebook Marketplace you know
whatever Auto Trader Auto Trader
whatever get it out there and sell it
and you're gonna pay it off just like
that and you have a little extra you got
any money in savings
uh I'm working on baby step one I have a
one and a half year old and then my
fiance stays at home with her I live
with my parents so I have no other bills
and I have a I have a very small credit
card that I'm gonna pay off planning on
this month is only 300 okay any other
debt
nope that's it I have no other bills
other than that okay one final question
for you does it have a Hemi
no it does not okay well that's good
Leighton because George has no idea what
that even I just know there's no idea
it's a fun thing to say hey late here's
the deal sell the truck I'm selling it
and with the uh extra you could pay off
the credit card and you're ready for
this if my numbers are right Leighton
and George correct me he sells the truck
makes two to three thousand on it he
pays off the credit card bill of 300
bucks and he finishes his baby step one
yeah it's that thousand dollars in the
bank and you're off and running my
friend and then you're a baby step three
if you get rid of the credit card now we
got an emergency fund now we can save up
and get a personal car down the road but
that's a lot of truck making 40K and the
truck's worth 28. what does he do George
get a cheaper truck maybe go for a
fifteen twenty thousand boat puller
later on down the road my friend love it
gotta love the uh the corporate car or
the government
ah it's good stuff all right folks tell
you what else is great you and your
calls they're lined up don't move more
the Ramsay show coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George camel it is a
free call for you to jump into the
conversation triple eight eight two five
five two two five of course we're going
to talk about your money but we talk
about other areas of your life as well
certainly relating to your money one is
work and and we you know we look at your
income as your greatest wealth building
tool a bigger shovel if you will to get
out of debt or to save for that house
down payment or saving for your kids
college and so on and so forth so I am
the work guy if you want to call me that
no overalls Today George I would love to
see more cookies whichever you choose
but I'll take your word question if you
feel stuck or if you're wondering should
I take a promotion should you quit your
job
um you know any work related questions
income related questions to work I'm
here to help on those as well and of
course George in in the shotgun seat
today with all of the money questions so
uh it is time for our blinds question of
the day you need to find out for
yourself whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
make sure that you use the promo code
Ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from Dan in Massachusetts
I'm finishing up my degree in accounting
with absolutely zero dollars in debt and
can get my CPA license to work at a big
company soon however I'm also
considering law school which would cost
around three hundred thousand dollars
not including interest the starting
salary for some lawyers and can be 210
000 in my city however for accountants
at Big firms that salary can take around
five to six years to get while law
school would only be about three years
to complete is it financially worth the
trade-off to go into debt if it will
increase my income faster or should I
stay with my accounting degree and
increase my Gallery at a slower pace
well you know these kind of questions
are always very nuanced and very
difficult to answer you know in a back
and you know without a band on the
fourth I don't have Dan on the phone so
I'll dive into
um the considering Law School
why are you considering law school are
you considering law school because of
the sheer Financial difference that you
see here it tends to the tone of his uh
question George leads me to believe that
he's thinking of law school primarily
for money reasons and I would always
caution against that I'd want to know
why did you choose to go into accounting
you know do you love the work does the
work create results that matter to you
um and and I got to tell you um
the 300 000 George I'm passionate about
this
you should never pursue a law degree
when you'd have to go into debt three
hundred thousand dollars to that school
here's why uh quick context several
years ago I had the opportunity to
interview a lawyer on the Ken Coleman
show based in Houston went to Vanderbilt
very high in school here in Nashville
and
he realized after the fact
that he could have kept taking the LSAT
got his GPA and his LSAT score to a
certain point where he could have gotten
free rides two smaller lesser known less
prestigious law schools okay but you
know you you don't think that and
largely you don't know that and so in
this situation a law degree is a law
degree unless you get it out of a
Frosted Flakes box right yeah and so I I
just would not be thinking about this
kind of money I would be trying to get a
free ride to a smaller law school if and
giant caps if law is what you really
want to pursue but to pursue a law
degree because you go well I can make a
little bit more money faster than I
could as an accountant an accountant has
just as much opportunity to move up into
a c-suite opportunity later on so I I'd
want to know those things before I
decided oh absolutely and his his
verbiage here the starting salary for
some lawyers can be 210 000. sure I've
got friends who are lawyers and they
went into deeply in debt for their
degrees and they're making 65k doing
immigration law or some types that
aren't at these big firms so this idea
that you're just going to have a high
six-figure salary as soon as you leave
Law School is also a farce so don't
believe that lie
and if it means hey I'm going to have
this kind of salary in five years that's
great if you love accounting stick with
accounting never get a degree just for
the paycheck that see the paycheck wears
off George well and how many lawyers do
we have out there that are resenting
ever having gone to law school that
didn't make it who still have their
student loans to pay off or who are
doing it going I want to jump into a
different field this is not what I
thought it was going to be I'm burnt out
I'm doing 80 hour weeks at firms that
don't care about me oh yeah so this all
points to the issue of higher education
the student loan crisis which we delved
into with our documentary borrowed
future and what's cool is we're
celebrating the one year anniversary Ken
of the borrowed future launch and we're
going to Premiere the film on YouTube
for the very first time very exciting
Monday October 17th 7 P.M Central we're
going to have a watch Party on YouTube
so you can go to our Ramsay show
highlights Channel and hit notify me and
that'll be your RSVP there and this is
our award-winning documentary if you
don't know but I didn't know about it
that uncovers the dark side of the
student loan industry history every high
schooler needs to watch this every
parent needs to watch this you've got to
share this with people in your life that
you care about and you can follow the
watch party on October 17th you can view
it on YouTube for free on demand beyond
that of course with ads if it's on
YouTube so here's what Bard future does
folks it shows you multiple stories that
really illustrate the question we just
read this idea that the law degree is
this you know this magical ticket but
and what it really is is a carrot and
it's dangling and it's tempting and it
it says one thing and it does something
completely different it wrecks lives
when you cannot afford to pay it back oh
yeah and it is uh it's a nightmare
you're gonna see these nightmares and
live in color it is a jarring uh but
also hope filled documentary we're very
very proud of its emotions the watch
parties I mean you're hanging out here
uh at the offices on a couch with
popcorn I tried to get deloney and I to
hang out and get some popcorn I don't
think he was interested but if you are
I'm happy to show up at the Coleman's
house oh should we as long as it's at my
house and I don't have to go anywhere
just your backpack they're just gonna
bring cameras in and and then are they
live our reaction are they filming us
like Mystery Science Theater Company we
would have to pay people to watch that
it's the opposite effect I don't think
that's true I think the people would
love for us to be piped in a little
small window uh and we were commenting
on on things
we could press pause and go on a rant do
you know what I'm saying oh my God plus
I think people would want to know what
kind of popcorn you would eat versus the
popcorn that I would eat which is I'm
going with something a little healthier
not the one that's sopping from the
microwave with the movie theater butter
you know I've got standards in my life I
know what would it be you're probably
the light pot guy what do I see it's
organic I'm gonna do my own salt on
there
very bougie see I'm going Orville
Redenbacher I'm a man of the people
extra movie butter when I pull my hands
out you can see the butter kind of
trickling down the side of my finger see
I'm a man of the people no thanks Tom
Hank George wants corn with the story it
was free range yes it had a life I want
it on the stove I want to be a Little
House on the Prairie making my popcorn
from scratch I wanted to make my belly
feel good that's all I care about what
it's gonna do you you got too much
thinking going on well popcorn or not I
want everyone to watch this and it's
gonna be fun the watch party hit the
details again it's going to be great fun
on October 17th 7 P.M Central it's a
Monday night you can watch it on YouTube
for free for the premiere and then
beyond that we're gonna have it with ads
of course on YouTube for free you can
still watch it without ads on Amazon
Prime Apple TV Google Play
ramsaysolutions.com you can rent it
there for just a few bucks but this has
started to disrupt this toxic student
loan industry you know all the pieces
involved the guidance counselors the
parents the colleges who have been
raising prices at an insane rate and so
we dig into all that there's stories of
heartbreak there's inspiring stories of
folks who did it debt-free including our
friend Christina Ellis that's exactly
right by the way uh this this
documentary is right in the center of of
what I believe are two perfect storms
that are coming and let me tell you what
the storm is creating there's a
different tide if you will George a wave
coming in and I just uh put this on my
Instagram account College enrollment is
down nearly 10 percent over the last two
years only 51 percent of gen Z teens
George are considering a four-year
degree that's a 20-point drop since May
2020.
uh the college is the only way to
succeed wave is going out and the no
degree required wave is coming in and
and these this is the situation because
here's what we're seeing with young kids
on their own they're saying I don't know
if the time or the money is worth it to
do what it is that I want to do these
kids are sharper than we give them
credit for so the you take that the
legitimacy and credibility of the degree
being questioned by young kids and then
the overwhelming crushing cost of
tuition stressing parents out and the
student loan crisis all of those those
two storms coming together uh oh watch
out higher ed Ramsey Solutions is right
there in the middle to help you out this
is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about life specifically
your money your work your relationships
so if someone offered you a career that
you love that
allowed you to show up every day and use
what you do best to do work that you
love to produce results that matter
deeply to you all for a ten dollar bill
would you do it George ten dollars for
that kind of clarity I can't speak for
America but that's a no-brainer yeah
well good news for the first time ever
you can get my get clear career
assessment for only 10 bucks this
assessment gives you customized feedback
to help you finally get clear on the
talents you bring to the workplace what
work really fires your heart up and then
what results motivate you every day then
it takes all that info gives you
professional possibilities and fills out
a purpose statement for you based on
those unique talents passions and
Mission and it allows you to have a
fifty thousand view fifty thousand foot
view of a job description so that you
can look for find and do work that you
love thousands of people who felt stuck
took the assessment and got
life-changing results one of our five
star reviewers Greg said the results
were as if you knew me my whole life you
really opened my eyes to my potential
and purpose it only takes about 20
minutes and now through the month into
the month of October it is only ten
dollars at ramseysolutions.com this deal
will not last the ten dollar deal is one
you should take the get clear career
assessment ten dollars at
ramseysolutions.com here's how I look at
it Ken to afford an hour of Consulting
with you over some coffee it'd be
astronomical but I can get a I can
through this get clear assessment and
you'd walk me through the same exact
things you would if we were in person
it's true it's actually true really
proud of the tool helped tens of
thousands of people and you know what
I've learned George and you know this in
your life you and I have very similar
career Journeys the circumstance is
different but but the the
characteristics very similar and
when you get clear it's amazing how
confident you become
but absent of clarity it kind of always
holding back a little bit paralyzed and
and this tool is designed to give people
real Clarity on to say that hey I could
do this this this or this there's more
than one dream job for people and uh and
this this assessment the assessment
gives you exact roles it could be a fit
for you and it starts to get you
dreaming yeah yep get you looking and
get you doing more importantly so there
you go check it out ramseysolutions.com
to get clear assessment Harper's Ferry
West Virginia is where we go next Lacey
is on the line there Lacey how can we
help
hi thanks so much for taking my call I
just have a quick question my husband
and I got married last December I'm 29
and he's 39. I have a Roth IRA with a
few thousand already in it and we're
making his soon we both have around
401ks but I'm concerned with food Ira do
we put the rest of our 15
contributions into my already
established his brand new one do we
split it is him being older matter
that's what I need help with
so he has a new one that has zero
dollars in it or is there some in there
already
it is brand new zero okay would you be
maxing both of these out or is there too
much you don't have enough income to do
that at this point
we would not be maxing them out so why
won't we could put the rest in mind I
wasn't sure the priority yeah at that
point the IRS sees the IRAs all the same
you guys file jointly
yes okay so it doesn't really matter
they're going to grow at the same rate
if I put a thousand in a brand new one
or I put a thousand and one you've had
for years the Thousand is going to grow
at the same rate uh if it has the same
funds in it
and so from a mathematical standpoint it
doesn't matter so I would just keep it
simple I would Max one out and
whatever's left over throw in the other
one
okay but him being older than me
it really doesn't matter because that
was what I was thinking since he was 10
years older he'll get access to it
sooner than than I would
um but sure he will have access to it
sooner but are you're not going to take
all the money out at once potentially
right
correct no so you're going to leave it
in there
um and you know you can talk about that
with a smartvester pro and work on that
kind of long-term strategy hey if we do
this bucket first then we do this bucket
then we can move over here we can do a
bridge account with a brokerage uh if we
want to retire early and then use that
money until we can have access to the
Roth IRAs they are really great about
mapping out a big long-term game plan
about how that would work out but from a
mathematical perspective today it
doesn't matter
so if you I mean you could withdraw
money from yours later on and it's the
same as if he withdrew money from his
because it's all your money
no you're right I didn't think about it
that way you answered my question thank
you okay we did it we at least answered
one today if nothing else George don't
ever ever ever sell yourself shortly I
appreciate it good advice you got good
advice that's what you do thank you
don't act so surprised all right next in
Springfield Massachusetts David is on
the line David how can we help
all right good to talk to you today I'll
give you a very quick rundown I'm 54. no
debt except for the mortgage that
balance is 130 000 and I am fixed at 2.9
um receiving an inheritance uh like
about 280
000. wow
um yeah I'm all the way up there about
that skyrocketed me right up to baby
step six slash seven
um I'm retiring in about six to seven
years I've got my 15 in the Roth PSP I'm
a government employee so
um with the Roth 401k and a lot of folks
are telling me do not pay off your
mortgage especially at 2.9 invest that
and in five years at whatever four or
five six percent then just pay it off
with the earnings
so I know what Dave Ramsey says but you
know what should I do oh so Dave's not
here today so he wants to know what
George well you know I've I Don't Stray
away from Dave's advice on this one and
the truth is what they're doing is
they're starry-eyed and if everything
goes perfectly and if the market is up
20 per have you seen the market David
I certainly have how depressed would you
be if you put that inheritance into the
market six months ago and now you're
looking at it going oh my gosh I still
have to make a mortgage payment I I
already lost fifty thousand dollars in
the market
yeah that uh that wouldn't be too good
no and on top of that these are taxable
accounts you're talking about so you're
gonna have to pay taxes on that and so
there's a lot of you know we could go
through the list of why but at the end
of the day this is your money your
friends don't pay your mortgage for you
every month so the question is what
would David do without a mortgage
payment what kind of life could he live
how much earlier could he retire could
it be four years instead of seven
because he doesn't have a mortgage
payment and now he can invest like a
madman and he sleeps better at night on
top of that because he doesn't owe
anyone anything
it's like there's the guys at church are
the ones telling me to pay off the
mortgage oh look at that so the those
who have a faith perspective they
understand Proverbs 22 7 the borrower a
slave to the lender
that's right there you go I mean that's
that's a whole other angle there but I
truly think that a life without debt is
just a more peaceful life and on paper
you can justify why you should invest in
the market and you can move things
around and do some tricky things over
here but at the end of the day your life
is valuable and it's going to be even
more peaceful and more joyful when you
have more margin
is
it's still okay if I don't get the tax
breaks not having the mortgage the tax
breaks if they want to talk tax breaks
they're just terrible at math because
you're trading you're giving a dollar to
the uh to the lender to get a
quarterback from the government yeah
have you read the actual numbers David
because I think people say that and it
makes total sense when it's when it's
not when there are no numbers applied to
it and you only get the tax break if
you're itemizing with the new tax laws
and so beyond that you're going to send
10 000 to A lender so that you can get
2200 for off of your taxes yeah that
makes no sense the amount of money you
will save and invest by not having a
mortgage payment is what you should be
focused on what it what is your what is
your gut telling you to do despite the
uh non-church friends and then the
church friends what do you think you
should do
I always feel better being free than pay
your house off David forget what
everybody else says
you do what's right for David i w w d d
That's What would David do do it you
agree with us we agree with you you're
gonna feel so much better about it boom
house is paid off
just like that
you're simple wow George you went from
church George to Jersey George I like
that that could be a new show very good
all right hey George Campbell thank you
sir great at times thanks to the crew
behind the class and thanks to you
America this is the Ramsay show
foreign
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we talk about
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman joined bye George Campbell this
hour the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five George here to answer the specifics
of money I'll weigh in and then I'm here
to answer any specifics on your work
life in a toxic environment afraid to
get out of it because you're in the baby
steps can I move through the baby's tips
and change jobs can I get qualified for
something else while on the baby steps
we'll take on those type of questions
and more let's get to it Denver Colorado
Chelsea is there Chelsea how can we help
uh thank you for having me on the show
today I'm really excited it's good um
I'll get to my question
um
my husband is getting is wanting to
change Industries and we were wondering
if we should use our emergency fund to
pay for schooling for him to change
careers
okay is it an emergency
um
kind of I
away from where he is at on the verge of
possibly depression
um in his work environment okay what is
specifically going on at the work
environment
um so she is just kind of
um getting talking down to being told
that he needs to work hours outside of
the normal work hours
um anything he says
um is getting thrown back onto him and
then he tries to change it it's not
getting fixed and it just seems that if
the boss doesn't want to work with him
anymore got it and how much does he make
is it salary or hourly position
she is salary staff well salary
um and he um
I don't know what it comes out to yearly
but he makes about 40 an hour
and
the training that he wants to get and
that you two have agreed that he needs
to get what is that and and and what
does it cost and what is it going to
allow him to do to move into
so this is where we wanted to call in
and see your guys's opinion on the best
decision to do this
um he's currently in the HVAC industry
and has decided he wants to go into the
trucking industry so uh he will need to
get his CDL license
um schooling is two weeks and it comes
out to fifty eight hundred dollars okay
for the full course and for the test
that needs to be taken okay do you guys
have any debt
um only our mortgage okay great all
right I got all the facts are you ready
Chelsea
what's going on yeah I know right you're
kind of like oh boy what what he's going
through at work sucks
but it's not an emergency he needs to
keep his big boy pants on he needs to
put up with it he needs to grit and bear
it as an old phrase that I would use
here this is not an emergency I don't
think it's to the point of even you know
toxic to where you know I don't make
light of the fact that he's almost
depressed and that it is a depressing
situation I would agree with that
however
he has a path out
in the in the in the form of a two-week
fifty eight hundred dollar training
course and there's such a need in
trucking that if he does a really good
job he can get paid really well and move
up and so we have a way out so there's
no reason to be despondent and depressed
um but I would put up with it until we
are ready to step into the trucking job
and we need that income to come up with
the fifty eight hundred dollars because
you guys can scrape it together I don't
think this is an emergency so I wouldn't
use the emergency fund for it I really
wouldn't
um but but in this case
you guys can figure this out he makes
really good money you can sacrifice in
some other areas you could sell some
things uh he could work on the weekends
or nights right now is a wonderful
part-time what they call gig economy
where you can go uh you're not in some
contract you're not doing another
full-time job my point is fifteen
hundred dollars you guys could cash flow
that and never touch your emergency fund
and that's what I'm going to tell you to
do
okay and then um would you still
decide doing that if the schooling is
the same hours of a work day and his
current job he can't work evening is it
better to find something to work
evenings to get through schooling yes
you said this is two weeks right it's
two weeks how could we plan for that I
mean does he have two weeks vacation
um it wouldn't start until the new year
all right George let's walk through this
if it's me I'm trying to figure out okay
we don't want an interruption in income
unless you guys could could you if he
were to resign and and for two weeks
uh now there's no guaranteed job at the
end of the two weeks correct
so we need to wait until we have the
other job lined up the offer is accepted
before we jump ship from this one well
and George brings up a good point and I
should have been clear I'm assuming that
he's going to go get a job
a trucking job it's a great need and say
hey I'm I'm uh if you're high on hire me
I'll go get the training like I would
assume that that's a possibility he
should be thinking about that not just
I'm gonna go get my CDL license and then
go look for the job I don't think you
have to do it in that order has he
talked to anyone in the trucking
industry Chelsea
um he just
um I think he just talked to one
gentleman a lot of them are looking for
like one years oh
um for decent pay
um so even if he goes into this industry
he'll go in as entry level so so you're
making a massive pay cut I just My worry
is the grass is not greener on the other
side and he's jumping in this because
he's depressed and he's going well I
guess Trucking I can make good money and
it's quick you know I can do the
training quickly but My worry is he gets
into this and trucking's hard I mean if
you've talked to people who drive trucks
it is not an easy life or a sustainable
one long term and so I just want him to
make sure he knows what he's stepping
into if this is a passion of his versus
well this is easy money it gets me out
of a toxic place there are places he can
work in HVAC that are not toxic I know
because we meet them at our entree
leadership events they run amazing
companies and they're great leaders does
he want to drive a truck
he does all right let me know he did it
before okay let me now again I'm not
going to try to apply this to everybody
but the trucking industry right now is
is in a they are in a four alarm
dumpster fire trying to find truckers I
think you guys need to do a whole lot
more research and a whole lot more
talking just to give me an idea and I
don't know if the Walmart trucking job
is available to you but Walmart is
starting truckers in the 90 000 range
you need to do a little bit more
research you guys need let me tell you
something I report on this stuff almost
on a weekly basis on the Ken Coleman
show about the need for truckers uh they
are they are Expediting training this
whole you got to have a Year's
experience of driving that's not
necessarily the case in in most places
so let's look at the universe of
opportunities near you all
um and then we decide what we're going
to do like getting through the end of
the year scraping together the sixth
Grand January hits he uses vacation time
does the training by cash flowing it
that's right bada bing bada boom there
it is George it's your sound it's it's
become your thing it's my theme now we
call him Jersey George he just gives it
to you straight uh I don't know
anyway what are we doing Ken I don't
know what you're doing well I will tell
you this make sure that you have a plan
here's the lesson from that last call
make sure I have a plan before we jump
no need to jump let's walk this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more first
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show I've
kept Coleman George Campbell joins me it
is a free phone call for you to jump in
to talk about your life triple eight
eight two five five two two five eight
eight two five five two two five if you
got any work calls I want George to jump
in on some of these got a toxic work
environment you need a little advice
maybe we'll change your name we'll
change your name your location if it's
sensitive I want you to take away in on
some of these I love that you know it
Riles me up to hear about this toxic
word culture and I host the entree
leadership podcast so we're helping
leaders grow in that area because
there's a leadership crisis in America
today as well and a lot of the stems
from that yeah it sure does so jump in
uh triple eight eight two five five two
two five first uh we'll get to Tulsa
Oklahoma Annabelle is there Annabelle
how can we help
hi
um okay so about six months ago my
husband and I sold a house bought a
house and bought a new vehicle and then
probably two months after that we
started listening to the Dave Ramsey
Show and we got super excited about
paying down our mortgage
um and becoming debt free so we set up a
budget and now that we have our budget
we're realizing there's not a lot left
at the end of every month to attack the
mortgage with we would have done things
differently if we would like gone in
with your philosophy but we didn't so in
our current situation I'm just curious
if you guys have any things that you
would change that we should go back and
do differently or going forward what we
can do to pay down our mortgage quickly
I love it well I'm so glad you guys are
on board you're doing a budget there's a
lot of good things happening here now
when you said you bought the new vehicle
was that in cash or do you have a loan
on it
we did buy it in cash so we we took out
um 130 000 from
and then we bought the vehicle in cash
great okay so you don't have any debt
except for the mortgage
yes that's correct and you've got you've
got a fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
we do awesome and so when you look at
your budget where are the biggest ticket
items that are eating up this income
purchase one that is it's our mortgage
is two thousand dollars a month and my
husband brings home six thousand so I
mean we have extra for sure and we can
absolutely afford our payments but that
takes a lot and then we just weren't
thinking about
you know the extra electric and gas and
water bills all of the other things that
come with a bigger home
um so that takes quite a bit of it
um and you guys are investing 15 of your
income into retirement
we are okay so 33 of your income is
going towards the mortgage a little
higher than I'd like we recommend 25 on
a 15-year did you get a 30-year mortgage
we did yes okay this is a big old
it is we're trying to um make we're
right now we're putting 400
um so it's a two thousand dollar
mortgage you're putting 2400 bucks a
month on it yes okay correct where I
told my husband
take we've I feel like we've cut down
our expenses quite a bit
um what's tricky is our season of life
is so busy my husband is in a busy job
already so he doesn't have time to
really take on extra work but his career
will continue to grow and hopefully make
more money
um I stay at home with our two kids and
I do a little bit of tutoring on the
side but like I just already feel
exhausted in what we do have going on so
I don't see us at least right now being
able to take on a ton of extra work to
make more money but that's a question
too of like where's the balance there
because I could take on more tutoring
jobs or do extra things if I needed to
sure well there's only two ways money
Flows In and Out and so we can increase
income Ken can help you in that area if
your husband uh you know could be making
more in his current role what does he do
for work
he's a CPA okay so the question is how
can we get him from going from 72 000
take home to a hundred thousand take
home and now we've got an extra 30k we
can throw at the mortgage every year
that would speed it up right and so
that's one area the other area is
spending less and so that's on the outgo
I would go through your budget
are you guys using every dollar right
now or something different
oh we just set it up on our own so we're
not using every dollar okay I'm happy to
give that to you guys for a year and see
if you like that better see if you see
any changes there it's great you can
drag your transactions in to track it
all and get on a plan there but the
other side is auditing your budget this
means going through every single thing
with a fine-tooth comb going are we
doing the best we can are we overpaying
for insurance we haven't checked in five
years we should shop around with Xander
and see if we can shave off 20 bucks
here you know what we're using these
four subscriptions out of the 15 that
we're paying for let's shave those off
for a season and see what that does for
our budget and you know we've been a
little lackadaisical in the food area we
could be better about meal planning not
eating out as much maybe we cut the
appetizers and the drinks maybe we do
take out so you got to go into every
area of the budget and decide where are
we willing to sacrifice and compromise
so that we can have more margin to pay
off this house early
okay so I have one other question that
goes off of that um within we give 10 to
our church in Thai but when my when we
lived at our previous house my husband's
income was way above what we were
spending on our mortgage so we had quite
a bit of extra cash and we gave
I think 350 a month above that towards
additional you know like a
a charity that goes to the poor and
things like that so now that we're in
our new house I recommended putting that
towards our budget or towards our
mortgage and my husband would like to
keep it that extra gift towards what we
were already doing he's super generous
so I'm on board with him but I mean what
do you guys think of that is it okay to
keep getting extra in that way or is it
better to knock out your debt while it's
so big I am in the boat that generosity
is never a bad thing and so I would keep
that because it keeps your hand more
open when you realize you know what this
money is not just for us it's to bless
others and that's the most fun we can
have with money so if you're doing it
out of reluctancy we've got to you know
do a heart check there and go well maybe
we should be giving us something we're
more passionate about if we're just
doing this to check a box but if
something that you guys are passionate
about I'm not going to cut giving and an
offering from that area I would much
rather cut it from somewhere else I'd
rather cut a subscription before I do it
from generosity so I would sit down with
your husband this weekend and go through
with a fine-tooth comb everything and go
are we getting a good you know we need
to call the cable because there are
really they upped the bill and we never
really fought it and so let's fight to
get that down 10 bucks and if you do
that in every area it's amazing what
happens you'll go oh my gosh we just
found a thousand dollars on our budget
because we started getting really
intentional yeah and then I just want to
go back to you know you and your husband
need to have a conversation
about kind of a vision casting
conversation about what he could do
where could he grow in the next year
three years five years seven years
because the income piece is a huge part
of this and once you get control of the
outflow then the idea of him as a as a
an accountant there's a lot of different
directions he can go it is a wonderful
um career path in the ability for him to
have several different ways that he
could go off of that core skill set and
that experience and so I would challenge
him as well okay what can I do to raise
my income substantially over the next
three five seven years and I believe he
can
okay yeah so all right thank you yeah
you guys got this I'm doing great you
know we do talk a lot about money and
getting control of your money but we I
just want to point out not because I
talk about work every day but but I
really want people understand for
decades David said your income is your
greatest wealth building tool and and
the idea of increasing your income
it is way more possible than people
think but I I want to challenge our
audience because I think a lot of people
hear that they go okay yeah yeah it
makes sense Dave or yeah can we get it
all right
but I think more people than than I
think will admit
they're comfortable where they are and
they're like I'm gazelle intense I'm
working the baby steps and the idea of
changing jobs or the idea of getting
some additional qualification or
upskilling to be able to make more money
and then oh gosh if I do that and I feel
like I gotta change and and go into a
new company or a new position
it's all too you know uncomfortable
because it has to do with change and the
unknown oh yeah and I just I just want
to point that out that that I you know
you can't forget that we live in the
greatest economy the greatest country in
the world and you can climb the ladder
and what if you were using the baby
steps and making more money at the same
time and if you've done everything you
can to cut down on that budget a lot of
the times it's easier to go out and make
5 000 more than it is to shave off
another five thousand a year off the
budget right and so that's what you've
got to dig into if you do both what you
described and then I'm saying how can I
increase my income we talk a lot about
compound interest how about compound
impact George
okay you know I'm serious where I'm I'm
getting control of my money and reducing
my expenses and living a less than I
make but I'm also increasing what I make
for the big picture I love that it can
be done we're not going anywhere how
about you call in and we help you as
well this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey show America I'm Ken
Coleman George Campbell joins me we're
so excited that you are with us uh every
time you hear or see someone do a
debt-free scream on this show it's
because at some point they said I've had
it I'm not going to live like this
anymore when you get mad like that and
do what they did your life will change
too right now inflation and your credit
cards are killing you you've been led to
believe that you're not
in control of your money but that's
wrong you have to decide
to control what you can control that's
you
your behavior and Financial Peace
University will walk you through a
proven step-by-step plan
that's helped nearly 10 million people
beat debt Master budgeting and build
wealth and you can join the throng stop
letting debt and money stress control
your life say I've had it and Take Back
Control start Financial Peace University
at ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com slash FPU
Austin Texas is where we go next Gavin
is there Gavin how can we help
thanks for taking my calls so I'm on
baby step number two and I was just
curious my last piece of debt is my
Tesla I have nineteen thousand dollars
left on it but the part I'm torn on is I
don't want to sell it because I have
free charging wearing that and with the
little to no maintenance that the car
provides it's actually very comparable
to the cash flow if I had a ten thousand
dollar gas car for example so I was
wondering what Dave and you guys would
recommend should I sell the car pay off
my last piece of debt today or should I
keep the Tesla at the 2.49 interest rate
and just try to pay it down as fast as
possible
all right so what's your income
so I'm a real estate agent and my income
varies quite a bit the last year to date
I've made a hundred thousand dollars
already some months will be 25 to 30
Grand in other months could be as little
as two to three grand so it's very
variable okay but on average you're
saying in a year you're going to make
six figures
yes sir okay and what is a Tesla worth
so the Tesla on Kelly Blue Book today
says a private party would pay forty
thousand dollars so I have about twenty
one thousand dollars in equity in it so
I could easily sell it in I have 10 or
15 000 gas car
I also have free charging where I
currently live and I save about six to
seven hundred dollars a month not paying
for gas and the car payment's 580 and
has three years left you're spending 700
on gas a month if you had a gas car
yeah that's what the app says well I
don't know if I trust the app and this
is coming from a Tesla owner but uh
laying out the numbers I don't do
anything for the gas savings uh the
numbers here uh don't shock me so you
make over 100k the car is worth 40K
that's reasonable you're making good
money in real estate why not just
aggressively pay it off
that's what I'm planning on I was just a
little torn because if I sold it today I
could be debt free today and I could
probably pay it off in the next three to
six months is my goal
um also with the interest rates
increasing in business having slowed
down considerably I don't know if I'm
going to be making 100K the next year it
just kind of depends on how things work
out since it's very commission based so
you're in baby step two how much money
do you have in the bank right now
I don't have that much I have a couple
Grand in the savings and my plan was to
you know either start increasing that
savings to the three to six months or be
aggressively paying off the car but I
was a little bit torn since like I said
I could pay it off today and just be
done with it
yeah I mean you love the Tesla I'm
guessing right
of course yeah I slept on the decision
for about three years before I bought it
I did tons of homework and I understand
it from the ground up I work with a lot
of Tesla clients I've been to the Tesla
Rodeo when they opened up the factory
here so I'm very ingrained they're super
fun yeah I don't I think you just pay it
off aggressively the next 20 grand
commission check you get be done with it
and don't go I'll put three grand on it
because I really want to build no now is
the time to pay off debt I would take
everything except a thousand dollars
throw it at the car this is time to uh
to really get aggressive at this thing
and the next few commission checks you
get be done with it and then save your
three to six months of expenses but no
nothing's pointing to you got to go sell
the car
okay but it's not for the gas savings I
think that's a great perk but I'm doing
it because it's not a huge part of your
world and you can pay it off quickly if
you're gonna tell me it's going to take
me take me three years four years to pay
this thing off with my income and it's a
50 000 Tesla and I make 40. I go sell it
today you're broke but that's not the
situation here
okay that makes total sense thank you
yeah and I just one little Challenge on
the work side of things I understand the
real estate market is in some way
slowing down there's no question about
that but I wouldn't accept that you know
if I was in a situation like that I
wouldn't go okay well the market is what
the market is I would be planning uh I
would be looking at okay what can I do
what kind of pipeline do I need to have
in order to keep up the pace that I've
kept up in the past I wouldn't accept
that well the market is what the market
is I you can still sell houses in this
market oh absolutely
um and so I just heard a tinge of that
and I want to challenge well tinge of
pessimism yeah with interest rates going
up and well it's cooling off I would
call it excusesm oh it's not a word but
I just made it a word it's like well you
know you can't pay it off as fast as I
like because no
and to your point pay the thing off yeah
and of course real estate slows down go
get a side gig yeah you can always make
money yeah there you go by the way that
app and the 700 on come on I don't buy
it that's a little outrageous what app
was that the Tesla app well of course
they're saying that that's what I was
telling him
yeah elon's no idiot he's he's juicing
the numbers because he doesn't want you
to get rid of him out to Gavin's point I
get free charging at work as well Ken so
there's a sweet perk thanks Dave and I
park right next to Dave just to make him
angry as he drives in and his Raptor
yeah it's a lot of fun yeah well this
car could eat mine for breakfast it
would be like a snack his Raptor but
it's fun I hope one day he accidentally
just drives over your car you know what
I mean I wouldn't turn it into the spot
and he doesn't realize and he cut it too
close and he just goes oh it's George's
Tesla I tell you this it would either be
accidental or very intentional oh I
think it would be accidental at first
but then he'd roll it off as intentional
he's like well it is what it is it is
what it is you go George here's a here's
a plug thank you here's a check and a
plug go get yourself another electric
toy well Rachel Park's next to me and so
for his own daughter to drive that thing
that really bothers me too much I don't
want to live my life trying to find the
next freaking Outlet all right I have
too much stress in my own house
at the camel house my wife drives one so
road trips we take the SUV it's no big
deal yeah that's not a problem I don't
like it uh let's go to Kelly next in New
York City New York Kelly how can we help
hi uh thank you very much for taking my
call you bet what's up because I
invested in a startup company
and the amount that I've invested I only
had 25 left to be paid off
however I'm working two full-time jobs
to pay this bill
my sister had generously offered to pay
off the remaining balance
I don't think I should do that because I
could probably have this paid off by
January
so why not just pay it off and say thank
you sister for your generosity but I got
this one because I don't want to create
any resentment between us I don't want
to feel like I owe you something even if
you did it as a gift I'm going to have
this feeling on my heart this is on me
and I don't want that on my conscience I
love you too much to do that so I
appreciate it but I got this in a few
months it'll be gone
that's my line of thinking but she was
all about
um
which is why I'm calling she's all about
Dave Ramsey he just says pay it off but
I'm like I don't have that money but you
will in the next three months
how much is it
right now it's seven thousand
and what's your income
my income this both full-time jobs is
56.
yeah I I just I think I would say what
George said and if she keeps pressing
you on it I would say what is causing
you to keep aggressively offering to pay
my debt I don't need you to I don't want
you to I've said thanks what is it that
is driving you to keep doing this I
would kind of put it back on her
well she's already she told me that last
night what is it she told me that she's
very concerned about my house because
I'm starting to fall asleep then I
shouldn't be
okay
uh appreciate that but again you already
told us that you don't need it and you
don't think you should do it so you know
be a big girl and say thanks sis I'm
okay I'm just tired and maybe you go to
one full-time job and find a different
one that pays you as well as both do and
that's an option speed everything up a
little bit it doesn't have to crush you
and if it takes a few months longer
that's okay
do it at your pace but with
intentionality there's something in your
gut that is telling you not to take the
money from CIS you need to honor that I
would trust your gut on this one thank
you so much for the call you got this
hang in there get some rest this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five George uh headline I shared the
other day on the Ken Coleman show and I
wanted to bring it to the Ramsey Show
CNBC did an article headline reads 50 of
workers are burned out
and productivity paranoia is making it
worse
uh so let me tell you what pre uh
productivity paranoia is George I've
never heard of this term I know uh I
don't know yeah no you're well you're
paranoid in general that's true but
productivity paranoia is the position
that companies via managers and leaders
are taking with the people that work for
them and the idea is is this is
specifically related to remote workers
and hybrid workers remote full-time
remote or the hybrid workers spending
some time in the office and then
sometime remote and so you were seeing
it with uh keystroke tracking on your
keyboard I've heard about that
monitoring uh your key fob you know on
the days you're supposed to be in uh
softwares that we reported one story of
a lady who got fired because she cooked
something
in her kitchen and her computer was
spying on her she was working in her
kitchen at home
and she was in a phone related job where
she had to make certain amount of phone
calls and she had her computer open
and the computer
software they were able to have access
to it and they were watching her on the
camera cook something in her own kitchen
okay cook a meal for lunch I didn't know
it was legal to run the camera without
your knowledge this is just a real life
situation I reported on this story this
is a big trend on Tick Tock so the lady
got fired over it and they were spying
on her in her own home okay so this is
the productivity paranoia so hey we
don't see you we don't hear you are you
working the hours that we say You're
supposed to work okay uh and then you've
heard the terms the great resignation
right where we had nearly 60 million
people quit in the last 13 months the
number continues to truck a long
September job report broke another
record of people leaving their jobs
and then of course I know because you're
Mr Millennial and Mr Tick Tock Mister
all the things on social thank you you
know about the term quiet quitting oh
yeah which is a phrase that was born on
Tick Tock and it refers to people who
are doing just the bare minimum so
whatever is expected of me I'm gonna do
that I'm not going to do anything more
because I don't want to burn out right
and so you got all this going on and uh
the reality is is that uh
ninety percent of workers this is a
Microsoft study so Microsoft has you
know office software and they did a
study 20 000 workers worldwide George
and this is the interesting dichotomy
all right between workers and leaders
okay ninety percent of workers report
they're productive at work
okay yet 85 percent of bosses say hybrid
work has made it hard to be confident
that those employees are being
productive right so the old idea the old
phrase out of sight out of mind plays
into can I be honest if I'm a worker
taking a survey why would I Market
myself as unproductive
right now obviously Microsoft did the
survey not the company they work for
right but still everyone thinks they're
more productive than they really are
yeah at the end of the day but this is a
true problem because when you're in
person I can see Ken at his desk I see
him in the meetings and with zoom you
might have a team meeting over Zoom once
a day but other than that yeah people
are going well I got my 48 minutes in I
finished my work for the day Ken why
does it matter what do I do with the
rest of the seven hours exactly and so
what's happening is you've got companies
that are saying I don't see you and and
so I'm going to track every movement
because managers are feeling the
pressure to report up to their
higher-ups that productivity is
happening
um which that's her that hurts culture
that hurts trust all the way around so
that adds to the burnout right because I
believe there are five causes of burnout
George at work and I'm curious you know
how many of our audience members are in
these are feeling these
um sources of burnout because burnout's
a thing but we've got to get to what's
the source of burnout one is a toxic
workplace what there's a lot of Gossip
backbiting politics lying going on
apathy things of that nature it's a very
toxic environment then there's your
overworked you just feel like you're
drowning the moment you pull into the
parking lot then there is you don't feel
recognized you're overlooked you're not
getting opportunities for promotions you
feel like you're not seen or you're
recognized for your work then there's
this straight up boredom you just have
no Challenge and then the final factor
that causes burnout is no purpose or
meaning in the work like you don't
there's no juice you don't love the work
the results of the work don't fire you
up so if you take all of that plus you
add in the fact that you feel like your
boss is your Nanny you've got big
brother monitoring you right like you're
in the crib go to sleep George you know
what I mean you know that kind of thing
and I think that's all contributed to it
and and one other piece of data from
this study this is not just a worker
issue this is a manager issue compared
with in-person managers hybrid bosses
struggle more to trust their employees
by a score of 49 to 36 percent and then
they say they have less visibility of
their direct reports work that's 54
versus 38 so in-person boss is more
trusting
hybrid or remote bosses not so trusting
and it's just creating a lot of tension
between the worker and the leader you
know it'd be a fun game to play if
you're listening and watching you put
the hand up and you go finger down if
you have a toxic culture finger down if
you feel like you're overworked finger
down if you feel overvalued and if
you're down to two fingers it's time to
peace out oh George that did you think
of that on the Fly that is how my brain
works that's impressive I was actively
listening but I was also going that
would be a fun game and that's a good
game
so works if you get down to one finger
one finger is a little different that's
uh it's a little bit different attitude
it's a spicy attitude different reply if
you're four out of five on that list Ken
you gotta go today yeah it was
absolutely right and we're here to help
with that you know leaders from an
entree leadership standpoint we can help
you uh in how you're communicating how
you're leading and then on the Ken
colemanship and I can help you I mean
again uh once you know what's causing
the burnout
it's like going to the doctor and going
I got sore knee the last thing you want
the doctor to say is well I've taken a
look at it and I can now tell you that
you have sore knee that's not what you
want that's Dr Coleman for you yeah you
want to know what's causing the soreness
get to the root of it let's get to the
in those five causes of burnout toxic
work environment you're overworked
you're underappreciated you're bored or
you have no meaning or purpose in the
work that can make you not want to come
into work very often and by the way not
only you don't want to come in it's
affecting productivity and that so
leaders are going I gotta track you I
gotta track you I gotta track you that's
not leadership that's Nanny ship and and
what followers are saying and people
that we're gonna go listen
I'll get the I'll get the work done but
treat me like I'm a human being treat me
with some dignity treat me with some
love show me how to do it train me to do
it better that's great leadership you
know so and Dave and I uh we just
released an entree leadership podcast
this week all about the difference
between a boss and a leader and
everything you're talking about that is
how would you sum it up that's bossary
yeah well I mean Dave talks about this
in the I'm not gonna I'm gonna tease it
here that's all I'm saying everyone
needs to listen to it but he talks about
all the things you're talking about does
the team feel valued do they care are
you pushing are you pulling how often
are you meeting with your team how
connected are you and that's one of the
reasons all you know 1100 of us are on
Under One Roof every day we just value
that as a team we think it builds
culture we think it builds trust we
think there's more productivity and it's
not from a big brother standpoint of if
Dave doesn't see you you're not working
but we just know the value of being
together in proximity physically and
Simon sinek I just interviewed him and
he said much of the same it's crazy how
much of it aligned yeah well you know
what's interesting about that I just
read some data nearly 60 percent of gen
Z
wants to work in person they do not want
remote work they are craving the
relationship Connection in the workplace
it's fascinating you don't see those
numbers of course with Gen X which is my
generation and Boomers but there is a
disconnect
between and again I'm not anti-remote
work okay if you can get it if you can
do it and be productive you got a good
healthy leader great but it does cause
all kinds of problems we're beginning to
see this in the data and Dr John delone
is always talking about the loneliness
epidemic we're facing as we just stare
at our screens and lose personal you
know physical connection with people and
that's one of the benefits I get from
just being here versus remote work you
got to be way more intentional about
that in your personal life I mean I just
for a moment want you to consider George
how much better your life is because you
sit three feet away from me I couldn't
even calculate it Ken I mean it's a
measure it's invaluable wow because we
get to say hi to each other and in the
high fives the fist bumps that's a
double blessing it is the two of us in
one room hey it's always a blessing to
spend an hour with you here you make it
easy it's well it's always big fun hey I
want to thank the team behind the glass
they keep us on the air in America we
want to thank you for listening this is
your show this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we talk about
your life your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George camel it is a free phone call if
you want to jump in we're here to help
you to give you some hope through some
practical clear steps forward triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five George you're ready to go game on
yeah you got all your answers your cue
cards ready to get voice references
ready Ken I mean this is wow here we go
uh Ben is up in Phoenix Arizona Ben how
can we help
hi uh first I just want to say my
parents are a huge fans of the show and
they've been teaching us the concepts of
financial peace for a very long time and
they just definitely wanted me to shout
them out for this but nice what are
their names
uh Jenny and Marianne Jenny and what is
it
Marianne there it is Jenny and Marion
thank you for being long time listeners
and and there is the shout out raising a
good kid all right how can we help today
so I've found myself in a pretty
fortunate position I just graduated from
May or I just graduated in May from
college and um I got a job I'm making 78
000 a year
um
I don't have any debt and I moved back
in with my parents
but I'm trying to decide if it's a good
idea to move out and I certainly would
like to
but I'm saving up for
um
you know I'm planning to get engaged to
my girlfriend pretty soon and um she is
uh gearing up to go to med school within
the next two years and thinking about
all the debt that comes with that uh I'm
just wondering if it's a good idea to
move out yet or yeah it's time to move
out man you got no debt you have a great
income it's time to fly the coop and uh
you know have some dignity on your own
and have that Independence
that's great to hear so can you I mean
it sounds like making 78k can you afford
a place on your own that's 25 of your
take-home pay
um yeah yeah I gotta ask you when George
said that you you were like oh it's
great to hear
why'd you need our permission what's
behind that are you feeling pressure for
Mom and Dad to stay a little longer
no so
um I uh everyone that I talk to at my
job has said
um you know I'll write that out as long
as you can oh and I uh yeah but they're
broke you're not
they want to stay children you're an
adult
okay yeah all right I mean I and then I
moved at 20 and it I think it really
there's nothing wrong with going home
for a season if you're trying to pay off
debt and really do something aggressive
like that but man it really stunts your
growth long term to just have that
safety net and just go well I'm just
going to live with yeah parents because
it's easier and I got meals here at some
point you got to be an adult and go I
got to pay my own insurance and learn
how to cook a meal it's absolutely right
I just I got to take the old man opinion
here on this one uh this is under the
guise of well it's financially smart to
stay with Mom and Dad that's just
avoiding responsibility uh this is the
generation that came up with the term
adulting which I can barely say without
spitting you know so yeah good for you
and your response uh
you need to do what you believe is right
and George is absolutely right it's
going to make you so much more fulfilled
being your own man and getting out there
so yeah go for it man my guess is your
take-home pay is probably somewhere in
the 4 500 a month range
uh yeah it's probably around 4 200. okay
so yeah if you can find a place for
about a thousand bucks in your area to
rent that's great if you need to get a
roommate that's fine too if the place is
2 000 and you get a roommate that covers
one of it then I think that's a wise
move I had roommates up until I was
about married and it was great yeah
so here's the deal turn off the noise
Ben like they're gonna criticize this
move when you go back to work you got to
be a big boy put your big boy pants on
and be okay with them disagreeing with
you
but that's real I mean let me just say
this in no way am I knocking Ben but
peer pressure is real I mean peer
pressure isn't just a middle school high
school phenomenon
you know I mean it really does affect
adults as well you got a chorus of
people going part of the pessimism about
everything's so expensive and this is
none of this is our fault and the other
Generations set us up for failure and
while some of that is true it's also
your responsibility for what comes next
yeah and you can't just sit back in a
corner and go as long as Mommy and Daddy
are here I'm gonna be okay I got a term
it's like quiet quitting it's lazy
living I'm just gonna live at home with
Mom and Dad this is your third term you
invented there was a excusesm compound
imp impact and now this one lazy living
I should probably take the rest of the
show off write those down I don't want
to hurt myself brilliant yeah there it
is all right Carlos is on the line in
Albuquerque New Mexico Carlos how can we
help
hey how's it going you guys we're having
a blast what can we do for you
guys
um I got a job offer and I'm kind of
I'm kind of stuck on whether to take it
or not all right what was the job offer
um
so the job offer so the job I do right
now is I'm I'm an automotive technician
okay and the job offer is basically to
go just to another shock so basically
I'll be doing the same thing but
they're offering me a dollar more
what's the jump from what to what
uh it's working from a dealership to an
independent job okay what's the numbers
is it 18 to 19
uh no it's from 32 to 33 yeah that
doesn't even matter
um let me take a wild guess you're
calling because
your brain and your heart are having a
wrestling match your brain's telling you
man it's a no-brainer you got to take
the other job they want you it's a
dollar more but your heart's going I
don't think I actually want to go over
there am I about right or am I wrong
you I mean you're you're about right
um I guess like my biggest thing is here
where I where I currently work you know
I have a lot of a lot of more leeway
here so they understand what do you mean
by leeway
like they understand you know what my
kids if they'll let me you know if I
have to go flexibility flexibility and
they value you
right yeah so here's the deal I wouldn't
even consider the new job unless they
would promise you the same flexibility I
wouldn't even consider it I can hear it
you know that's why your heart's going
um do we really want to leave and leave
this type of value this type of
flexibility that's really good for us
right for a dollar more it's just not
worth it on paper now if the if the
other if the independent shop will
promote will promise you the same
flexibility and and value the same way
but you're gonna have to ask people who
work there
you're gonna have to talk to people who
already work there and go hey this is
what I have at the other shop you think
they'll allow me to do that here they'll
tell you the real real you know get an
idea what the culture is like over there
by talking to guys and gals that are
doing the work not the leaders who are
interested in hiring you uh but Carlos I
unless you find that I'd stay where you
are George I'm with you on that one it's
not worth it if it's going to be a
tougher work environment you go if this
wasn't worth the extra few thousand yeah
when The Head and the Heart are in a
wrestling match you got to listen to the
heart always
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
George Campbell we're here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five talking about your life your money
your work your relationships triple
eight eight two five five two two five
right now is the time of year when it's
make or break when it comes to our goals
we're heading into the holiday season
and it's hard to stay motivated George
loses all motivation for his figure
around Thanksgiving
you you wear the Sans belt pants I gain
at least two pounds
uh but whether it's uh finding a better
job making more money paying off debt
building stronger relationships it can
be hard to keep the momentum going but
in a couple weeks we have the day we
could call it a a a a a a Kickstarter
day to kick start momentum
uh to keep that momentum going for you
we call it the smart conference it's one
of our biggest events we're going to be
in Dallas for day-long event where
you'll get advice from leading experts
on money personal growth career mental
health and your marriage join me and the
rest of the Ramsey personalities Dave
Ramsey Dr John deloney Rachel Cruz
George Campbell Christina Ellis and it
is going to be a fun day it's live in
person October 22. get your tickets
before they sell out go to
ramsaysolutions.com events that's
ramsaysolutions.com
events uh it's gonna be a fun day George
there's a live band and I'm gonna
audition to be in it I'm real excited I
don't understand you might be uh making
a cameo I'm making I realize I'm on
stage about four times at this event Ken
yeah are we allowed to talk about the
other fun thing we're all doing
taboo yes I don't know if it's if we can
let the cat out of the bag but let's
just say that it's the most fun we have
at an event high energy High
entertainment value no question not your
grandma's event but bring her yeah she'd
love it your grandmother would love it
uh I might invite her you might invite
your grandmother I don't know that she
can make on a plane these days yeah all
right bless here you go all right bless
her heart what do you call her uh tetta
say that again that's Arabic for a
grandmother say that again like t-e-t-a
Teta yeah did I say that right that was
mildly offensive but I think you passed
the test pass oh No George you can't
walk me into offending something no you
did pretty good there was an attempt
made yeah my version of your
grandmother's name is far better than
you saying Toyota that is true all right
I get heckled by the gang
Toyota instead of Toyota
who talks like that I'm from Boston dude
what do you want from me people in
Boston don't say Toyota whatever that is
okay they don't butcher it like that
he'll tell you all right very good
speaking of Boston and you know the
right the Rivalry between the Red Sox
and the Yankees Big Apple Thomas is in
New York City Thomas how can we help
uh hi guys how you doing today well
we're having too much fun as you can
tell as a matter of fact
games tomorrow night I'll be going to
look for the playoffs
you got to see Aaron judge maybe hit one
out of the park
I hope so it's nice to be in the
playoffs again this year what I'm saying
the Red Sox aren't there are they
no they are not I just wanted to point
that out I'm done with sports talk with
Ken how can we help Thomas what's going
on yeah let's get on look we're not
letting out here to talk about sports
all right listen I received I've uh
inherited about 88 000 from uh my father
who just passed sorry to hear that oh
yeah oh no that's okay because he had he
was 95 years old he had a great Mark wow
that's what I mean I mean people say oh
you're sorry I mean 95 years old he
lived a great life I hope to live that
long come on Amen you and me both pal
let's celebrate it and what a legacy to
leave you with with a chunk of money as
well to bless you yeah I mean it's not a
huge chunk but it is you know like I
said it's 88 000
um and I'm trying to figure out what to
do with this money or where to put it
for now like I said I'm 55. I mean I
have a good job I earn a good living I
have a pension with that job I have
small savings account I pay my bills
um so it's not necessarily I need to up
uh read the money necessarily but you
know the end is coming soon uh being 55.
well not the end but yeah wait a second
I thought we were living 40 more years
got dark real quick Thomas
you want to retire in the next you know
five or ten years we got you we got you
well ten years I got to go at least 65
to get uh my full pension anyway okay so
do you have any debt
I do not I got rid of my debt when I got
divorced okay so no debt you have you
said you have some money in savings do
you have a fully funded emergency fund
three to six months of expenses
how many three okay you got like 14 15
grams and what kind of account is the
88k in was it a traditional IRA
Q uh it came from a it came from an
annuity and and uh Ira I think okay
I mean I literally I have the money all
the the um it's in your bank yeah no
well I have a check I have a check in my
draw and I have uh they direct deposited
um you want account direct deposited
automatically into my savings account uh
about 45 000. have you looked into the
tax implications
are there any on this sure I was on I
was told by um an attorney that I won't
be
um taxed on this inheritance okay I just
wanted you to triple check that before
you go you know spend it and then tax
day comes and go you owe us 20 grand
yeah I'm gonna get back 47 you know 30
40 on most probably right yeah so I
would work with a tax Pro on that just
to double check depending on the type of
account uh but if if I'm in your shoes
I'm going to apply it to my next goal
and if that's you know maybe add some to
the emergency fund I'm gonna do you have
a house right now do you have a mortgage
I do not I rent okay do you have any
aspirations of being a homeowner
you know I did that
they're done 20 something I
was 20 something years I was married for
20. the house ended up we ended up
losing the house due to the divorce
through foreclosure and so then I had to
file bankruptcy in the whole nine yards
oh my goodness going forward yeah but
going forward that was uh 11 years ago
okay going forward I've you know filled
up my pants my britches and then I kept
going and I'm in pretty good shape right
now okay I might consider it only
because if you live to 95 like pops
that's 40 Years of rent going up and
expenses going up and so I'd rather you
have a fixed expense with a mortgage and
maybe you can tackle that and pay it off
and this money can help kick-start that
uh it did it did cross my mind but I
mean the housing market is not it's not
a joyride right now sure but also it's
not going to be a joy ride it's 40 Years
of increased rent in New York
right right so that also let me so on
this on this path though George that
you're bringing up I think this is good
Thomas in 10 years from now let's fast
forward 10 years and you retire would
you stay in New York or would you be
open to moving to another place I
probably I mean technically I'm in New
Jersey and I'm at the Jersey Shore
technically So when you say New York I'm
not necessarily in New York City sure so
you know what I mean I mean I can afford
the rent here the housing market is
still kind of crazy I could probably buy
something but then like you just said uh
George about being you know
um 10 years from now and then you know
what are you what what are you gonna do
you're gonna stay in Jersey or go to
Florida or what I'm not sure you're
getting really close to my mind I'd be
thinking about it
you have the worst case scenario you
could I could just sell real estate at
any time you know what I mean that's not
yeah and that real estate would
appreciate over the 10 years while you
decide and so now you've been building
Equity the house has gone up in value
you sell it and now maybe you could pay
cash for something in your next spot
versus having zero assets to your name
so I just want you to consider it I
think it's a great part of a retirement
plan to have an asset like a home that
will continue to grow in value and you
control your biggest fixed expense in
retirement which you know number one is
probably housing number two is going to
be Health Care
right right so something to consider
with the inheritance but if you need to
upgrade the car you know I like to do
three things when it comes to money give
it save it spend it so I'd start with
the giving if you want to give some of
it and be generous you want to save some
of it add to the emergency fund maybe
you know max out a retirement account
and then with the rest enjoy some of it
too
um yeah I guess so then in other words
putting it into an annuity or something
like that not uh I'm not a fan of
annuities I want you you know maxing out
IRAs 401ks solid retirement accounts I
wouldn't mess with annuities at this
point you know talk with one of our
smart investor Pros ramseysolutions.com
uh find shovel in your area go meet with
them talk through your options and uh
they're going to give you some
tremendous advice so there you go I
thought that was fun throughout the show
today I called you Jersey Georgia and we
take a call from Thomas who's from the
Jersey Shore and he had the great accent
to go with it yeah you should have said
the bada bing bada boom with him that
was the perfect moment you missed it but
there it is you missed the office 100 of
the shots you don't take there it is
don't move more Ramsey show coming right
up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
back to the Ramsey show America thrilled
that you are here with us I'm Ken
Coleman he is George camel the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five Kevin
is joining us now in Laguna Beach
California Kevin how can we help
hey guys appreciate you taking the call
you bet
um yeah so I've uh been with my company
for 15 years now I've moved into the VP
of sales role four years ago
um due to covid we went from 50
employees down to 11 we're back up to
26. but with that you know VP of sales
turned into marketing social media
partner business
um a lot more than it was maybe two
three years ago and um yeah have a job
offer on the table that is a lateral
potential move a little bit less in the
pay but definitely a higher ceiling and
just kind of wrestling and struggling
with do I stay where it's comfortable
quote unquote or do I kind of go out on
a limb and and risk something after 50
years at a company it's kind of hard to
hard to walk away from what you know
yeah I think you've laid out a pretty
clear
um opportunity and I think I've got an
opinion on this one but I want to know
how much less pay and then for how long
yeah so current my current job as a
salary of 205.
um and then bonuses on top of that but
the bonuses are
we'll just say 205. the new job uh has a
base of 160 with an on-target earning of
190 for year one and then year two they
haven't laid out what that looks like so
it's a
20K 25k for the first year cut well you
said 205 and then 190.
so yeah let's yep okay so that's 15.
yep so
um
and then the question is year two
because that's what you said year one is
190
um you know if you hit everything
um
what do you think year two and year
three look like
they're putting that together by Friday
so I should have more information on
that um yeah I'd want to know what that
ladder looks like because the way you
laid it out is all right Ken I make a
lateral move
um
professionally
uh as far as title and responsibility
but less pay
the 15 grand less pay for an opportunity
to climb I would always consider that
because I look at it as well how long am
I going to have that deficit and it
doesn't seem like very long they're
going to get you the numbers and I think
you got to weigh it there but the
opportunity to take a an opportunity to
get a higher ceiling or the way you put
it higher ceiling I'd put it as I've got
a ladder that I can get on and climb and
you know I don't feel like
that you love the environment you're in
now it may not be bad I'm not saying you
hate it but I don't think you love it
and I don't think there's much of a
ladder or if there is one it's not one
you want to climb is that fair I'm
reading in between okay yeah now I
report to the owner of the company so I
mean I am I am as high as it goes right
now yeah see um I am a I always preach
progress because that's just how humans
are wired
you know I mean Kevin that doesn't make
you a bad person that makes you a human
we want to make progress we want to grow
so I want to go where I can grow and if
I've got to go if I've got to go
backwards temporarily so one step
backward in order to take two steps
forward
as long as I can absorb the pay cut and
it is a short-term sacrifice then I
would absolutely do it
yeah okay yeah and I mean and things
that they're going to lay out hopefully
my Friday's also equity in the company
that's it
I I'm hoping and assuming you're in a
great place financially making this kind
of money
we're comfortable okay I mean no debt
emergency funding we're comfortable
investing 401K all that stuff so you can
afford to take this pay cut it's not
going to affect your budget that much
yeah and the wife is also a nurse that
could go back you know a couple more
days a week wonderful in the interim
yeah that's um so by the way we've got
options yeah and that's what I want to
point out to the larger audience when I
say absorb it that's what I'm talking
about you're not you know it's not a
four alarm fire and you're all of a
sudden struggling and having to live off
credit cards and all that crap and you
know yeah you can actually do this and
you're in a place to do it so uh you
don't have to take it right you could
you could keep your options open but I
certainly would listen all the way up
until they give you all the details and
answer all of your questions
yeah so I've been trying to get out for
about four years now good so I've been
I've been looking this feels right
doesn't it
it feels right
um it's just kind of the unknown but
also kind of the pay cut and it's the
people who are closest to me and I guess
who care about my soul are saying take
the job oh right like that's that to me
is even more important than my or
George's advice I don't know Ken's
number one for me but I know I get it
yeah I think you know what to do Kevin
yeah I mean listen this is this is good
for you you gotta listen to your heart
on this one uh let's get all the details
and if it feels right I'd walk into it
absolutely because you because you'll
climb and you'll look back on this as I
think a watershed moment in your life
yeah
awesome yeah you're the man appreciate
the Insight yeah man absolutely it's one
of the reasons people do this plan is
because it gives you options and when it
comes to situations like this it's not
well we have four hundred thousand
dollars in debt to clean up so we can't
take this jump we can't take the pay cut
it allows you to do these kinds of
things yeah absolutely right but let's
but let's also put this in quick context
um
even if he was in the debt snowball like
if he was you know paying off debt
and he could absorb this by his wife
going back to work uh selling some
things cutting the budget yes which high
earners tend to have yeah I still would
consider it it's not long term we're not
taking a long-term pay cut and if we can
absorb it so if I can sacrifice in my
finances if I can sacrifice you know
what I'm eating on rice and beans beans
and rice if I if I'm cutting the cable
if I'm sacrificing all these areas that
we do Financial we can also sacrifice a
little bit professionally in order to
get going forward our Fringe on Maxwell
yeah I worked for John for years you've
had the chance to interview him you know
it he said one time it's a beautiful
little phrase you got to give up to go
up and and what do you have to give up
sometimes in order to go up and if you
can handle it I'm not saying it's the a
blanket
uh automatic yes take a pay cut to make
more money in this in the long term but
but sometimes it's the right move and
you and you make the sacrifices
necessary so there you go it's a good
word let's go to Michael in Tampa
Florida Michael how can we help
hey how are you thank you for taking my
call you bet what's up
hey so basically my fiance and I we just
paid off we're working towards um saving
for our um three months of expenses but
my question is
I just got a job that's like an hour and
a half away and we're trying to
basically save up for a home to kind of
get us closer to my job
um I remember Dave was talking about how
he was okay with the five percent down
for the mortgage but I I kind of want to
know the reason why like what's between
like
what's the reason between like the five
percent ten percent I know the twenty
percent uh you I can avoid the PMI but
since this is a hectic Drive I kind of
want to we want to move
faster than wait until we get to 20 if
that makes sense sure well number one
the options are not either we buy a home
tomorrow or we have to commute an hour
and a half I mean you guys could rent
for a while it may not be fun you may
want to be a homeowner but that's number
one is to just realize you have more
than one option here number two the five
percent is for first-time homeowners
which it sounds like you would be
right and that still has to be within
the parameters of a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage uh and the payment can't be
more than a quarter of your take-home
pay around right and so it's hard to do
that with five percent down it depends
on your area if you live you know in a
rural area in the midwest you could
probably get by with that living in
Tampa I don't know how those numbers
would work out for you can you put five
percent down and still have that be a
reasonable payment
um I I don't know yet that's why I
wanted to call you guys because you guys
are able to like dumb it down for for me
we try to put the cookies on the bottom
shelf and partially because I'm not that
intelligent so George it really
understands dumb I can't help it it's
right there yeah so Michael I would jump
on to ramseysolutions.com click on the
mortgage calculator and start to play
around with those numbers and you might
find that you know what we're gonna have
to put 15 down to have this be a
reasonable payment on a condo and a town
home instead of a single family home and
so either way it may not be ideal your
first house is never going to be the
nicest house you live in so you've got
to understand that and do not combine
finances until you are officially
married and so I heard some language I
wasn't sure but wanted to clarify that
but you can be a homeowner but if you do
it right now the home might own you and
that is my fear so do it the wise way
even if that means going slow
he is George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman
and this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture today is Colossians 2 8 see to
it that no one takes you captive through
Hollow and deceptive philosophy which
depends on human tradition and the basic
principles of this world rather than on
Christ Our quote from Alexander Hamilton
don't start singing George I wouldn't
dare caution an investigation are a
necessary armor against error and in
position
now see you got to read that one twice
because they use good words back then
ten dollar words they don't make them
like they used to yeah uh that's uh then
they soak on that one for a little bit
he's George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman
this is the Ramsey Show so excited that
you were with us hey if you like the
show please consider subscribing leaving
a review and sharing it with a friend
that's how we grow and you're a big part
of that so there you go Josh is on the
line in Buffalo New York Josh how can we
help
hey guys how's it going great to get the
chance to talk to you guys yes sir good
to talk to you
all right so I've got a quick question
about my wife's retirement plan
um we're going to start investing
shortly
um we took a little pause just to pay
off some debt and buy a house
um so my question is
we have the option to do a Roth 401k
with our financial advisor or she works
for the hospital and her
um the hospital offers a 457b Deferred
Compensation Plan
um and really just my question is should
we do the 457b through her work or a
Roth 401k with our advisor
how has your advisor allowing you to do
a Roth 401k oh I'm sorry not a 401k a
Roth IRA oh there we go I was like I
have never heard of this I was thinking
the same thing my mind is blown okay so
you've got the IRA option Ira or a 457b
yeah now there are such things as Roth
457bs do you know if she has a Roth
option there or is it just traditional
it's traditional it's not it's not rough
okay so what we our outlook on investing
in our framework is that match beats
Roth beats traditional in that order so
does she have any match with her
employer there's no match no matter okay
so beyond that we are going to take
advantage of all Roth options available
to us and it sounds like right now that
would be a Roth IRA for each of you
correct and so I would fully fund the
Roth IRAs that's of 6 000 a piece and if
that doesn't get you to that 15 of your
household income then we're going to
move to the 457bs and put the rest into
that
gotcha what do you have available so so
I've got a Roth 401k through work and
then which I'm contributing to get the
match and then a Roth um Ira with our
advisor okay cool and I mean I'll tell
you what I do personally what my wife
does she works here at Ramsay we do all
15 into our Roth 401k we have great
retirement options and funds in that and
so because the Roth we just do all of it
in there
you can move to the IRAs
gotcha okay yeah that was a question I
could have asked too because uh right
now I'm just I'm just doing enough to
get the match with my 401k at work sure
and I'm just doing the other what is it
14
um I think it's six percent it works so
four percent into uh what's the magic
word
uh six percent but only 25 cents on the
dollar oh okay okay so be honest you
want to get to 15 total of your
household income invested
right okay so between those two and
there are income limits with the Roth
IRA so if you go beyond that what is
your household income
uh 140. okay so once you guys hit that
threshold you can still contribute to a
traditional IRA you can look at things
like backdoor Roth IRAs Mega backdoor
Roth IRAs and so I'd work with your
advisor when you guys do get to that
point because I have a feeling your
income will continue to go up but take
advantage of the Roth options and then
whatever's left over throw it in that
457.
awesome that's that's what answer my
question that's awesome yeah thank you
Josh appreciate the call I want to go
back I want to go back into the call
because we've got new people watching
and listening every day and you said it
really quickly and I want to break it
down for maybe New listeners or viewers
you said way we look at our investment
strategies we say Roth beats match beats
rough beats sorry match beats Roth beats
traditional I can't even say it it's a
mouthful I'm take it away from me but I
want you to simplify it right and I want
you to simplify it a little bit more
sure so why match beating Roth why Roth
beating traditional I want you to so
number one we only encourage this once
you are completely debt free and have a
fully funded emergency fund all
investing should be paused until you get
those things taken care of once you've
got those taken care of we move to baby
step four fifteen percent of our income
into retirement and we say match first
because that is a 100 return on
investment right let me explain that if
your employer matches four percent that
means if I put in
four percent my employer automatically
throws another four on top of that right
I just doubled my money if we were in
Vegas and I put 100 bucks at the
blackjack table I now have 200 bucks
boom I knew you'd appreciate it
boom hundred percent return there it is
now we moved to Roth because that is
going to grow tax-free so you're using
after tax dollars to invest but the
money will grow tax-free and you can
withdraw it tax-free right and I love
that because when I get to retirement if
I have two million dollars in my Roth
IRA you got two million dollars two
million dollars and Uncle Sam already
took his cut years and years ago yeah
which means I actually have two million
dollars right and so you're also betting
on the fact that taxes will continue to
go up as we get older
and historically that's that's has been
the case and so and then the traditional
and then traditionals where we go last
which is tax deferred you're going to
pay taxes on this later down the road
right but you're going to use pre-tax
dollars to do it yeah and so that is the
last thing to take advantage of beyond
that if you are like I ran out of all
those options you can just go into a
taxable brokerage account which is
non-retirement funds and a lot of people
use this as a bridge account Ken so
let's say Ken wants to retire at 50. but
he doesn't have access to his Roth IRA
and his his 401k without penalties until
later on in life and so this bridge
account can be used to where you have a
taxable brokerage account you invest
with a smartvestor pro or whoever in
index funds mutual funds and you might
have a million dollars in that brokerage
account
that you can now use to get by the 10
years until you have access to the rest
of your funds yeah and so there's a lot
of cool investing strategies this is
like next level wealth building and part
of our plan is we want you to build
wealth and give generously and it's
amazing what happens once you do that
especially early on as we continue to
get calls of people in their 20s and 30s
going we paid off the house Ken yeah
what do we do now yeah well now you have
30 40 50 years to continue to build
wealth and leave legacies and leave
inheritances we get so many calls about
inheritances and I love it because it
tells me that person cared enough to
leave a legacy yep I want to also you
were rolling through George because you
got this stuff down but you were
rattling through the strategies here the
back door Roth this is important for
people to make a certain amount of
income explain that so if you fully fund
your traditional you know Ira for
example but you make too much income to
qualify for the Roth IRA well you can
convert that traditional after the fact
to a Roth and what that means is you're
going to have a a small tax burden
because you're converting those funds
and we only encourage people to do that
once they're in baby step seven right
because it's going to cost you right in
taxes and I'd rather that money go
towards paying off the house and
investing and all those things and so it
can be a great strategy for those that
hire earners who are going well I want
to make sure that I'm investing as well
uh as as well as I can and so those
backdoor options are still it's it's not
really a loophole it's completely legal
yeah Biden was in talks about removing
this yes yes it hasn't actually happened
we got a lot of calls people freaking
out going well they're going to get rid
of it and the threshold for that income
the Roth IRA let me see that what the
income Roth is is it is it is it 180
Roth IRA income limits I'm seeing uh if
you earn more than 144 or 140 in 2022 if
you're married and filed taxes jointly
it goes slightly over 214 for uh for a
married filing 214 married filing
jointly okay yes and so that's an option
there if you can't contribute to the
Roth IRA if you are above that in which
case you still have other options uh
okay real quick to kind of put a bow on
this we have a great resource at
ramsayslutions.com that retirement
calculator is a wonderful time I love it
uh so tell people about that give us 20
seconds on that great 30 seconds on that
great yes ramsaysolutions.com you can
click on our free tools and check out
the retirement calculator and what this
does is give you a really clear picture
about what it's going to take to retire
when you want and to afford the
lifestyle you want because a lot of
people say well Ken when can I retire
and I go what kind of Life do you want
to leave yeah there's a lot of people
who go is it too late you can retire
with 800 000 you can retire with 10
million it just depends on the lifestyle
you're looking for but this gives you a
clear picture you put in your age the
age you want to retire how much money
you currently have in Investments how
much you're contributing monthly and
what you think your annual return will
be we say you know eight nine ten
percent that's realistic and that gives
you a clear picture about what life's
gonna look like 30 years from now 10
years from now it's doable
ramseysolutions.com check it out it is a
wonderful tool hey George Campbell
always full of great information good
times I had no idea you were that verse
in all the retirement stuff I'm a giant
nerd Kenneth I can tell you what it's
it's why Dave can go on vacation let's
just be honest he deserves it hey good
stuff good hour I want to thank the team
behind the glass for keeping us on the
air and you America for listening this
is your show it is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
folks Ken Coleman here did you know the
Ramsay show is one of the most popular
podcasts in the world to get your daily
dose of advice on life and money check
out all of our shows from the Ramsay
Network wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]